this is the massasauga rattlesnake it is  on terriers only venomous snake but it's  more scared of humans than we are of it  Maseo sagas aren't very large growing up  to 3 feet in length their skin is gray  to dark brown doubled with darker  splotches along its back their tails  rattle as a warning  yet they won't strike unless they have  no choice that's because meso sagas are  shy and prefer to hide than bite their  enemies unfortunately they can't hide  from encroaching human development which  combined with intentional killings from  over exaggerated fear have caused a  large decline in its Canadian population  this is the massasauga rattlesnake